sagt uns was ist da los ist wirklich
unglaubliche bilder wir sehen also
tatsächlich wie sich menschen wirklich
bevorraten mit böllern sie stehen in der
schlange vor einem lagerhaus und
schleppen also wirklich kartonweise
böller batterien raketen raus und man
denkt eigentlich tatsächlich es ist doch
eigentlich verboten aber es gibt halt
einen trick von diesen verkäufern die
sagen wir dürfen an gewerbetreibende
verkaufen das ging doch auf den ersten
blick auch erst mal vernünftig klar
vielleicht jemand der selbst damit
arbeite als profi pyrotechniker zum
beispiel
aber nein diese menschen die wir da
gesehen haben das sind menschen mit
gewerbeschein ist können aber friseure
es könnte klempner sein es können
pflegedienstleiter sein also
selbstständige die mutmaßlich wir wissen
es natürlich nicht hundertprozentig für
ihren privatgebrauch dort bella kaufen
und das legal also das illegale ist wenn
sie es jetzt zünden sie dürften alle
legal kaufen müssten es aber dann jetzt
sozusagen einlagern bis man dann
hoffentlich nächstes semester wieder
feiern darf wenn dies jetzt morgen ab
feiern dann wird das ist ganz unbedingt
das problem aber natürlich darf der
großhandel und das ist auch ein
großhändler der nur an profis letztlich
verkauft darf halt nicht an ein klempner
an einer frisur verkaufen nur weil die
einen gewerbeschein vorlegen und der
verkäufer auch damit konfrontiert er
sagt na ja da gibt es halt da gibt es
lücken in der verordnung ist die so
genannte sprengstoff oder sprengen
verordnung da steht eben nur drin
feuerwerkskörper dürfen nicht an
verbraucher also an uns verkauft werden
wohl aber an gewerbetreibende haben wir
irgend gefühl dafür wie oft so etwas in
deutschland gerade passiert wie viele
solcher fälle es gibt dass leute in
ihren garagen in ihr leben kürzlich doch
bella verticken ja sind offenbar sehr
sehr viele also wir haben einen
informanten der hat uns allein heute
glaube ich sieben adressen von leben nur
in norddeutschland geschickt weil er
sich auf diesen bereich konzentriert hat
aber das greift wirklich um sich und wir
haben mittlerweile jetzt auch eine
stellungnahme des ordnungsamtes in
schwerin das spielt er in schwerin
da war eine streife vor ort und die
ermittler jetzt ob gegen diesen
verkäufer den wir gesehen haben dann ein
ordnungswidrigkeitenverfahren eröffnet
wird
vielen dank frank für diese einblicke
also wie böller verkaufen deutschland
jetzt momentan an
auch ausgeben 'jetzt morgen weniger in
deutschland gebildet wird weil man eben
schwerer am ball heran kommt glauben sie
es wird dann am ende auch weniger
verletzte auf den kranken auch in den
krankenhäusern geben
das glaube ich persönlich überhaupt gar
nicht weil ich kann ihnen sagen die
leute die sonst bei uns hier in berlin
einkaufen
die wissen wo man noch feuerwerk er
kriegt und wir sind auch nicht weit weg
von den grenzen
die leute haben sich eingedeckt die sind
ja bis an die zähne bewaffnet muss man
ganz klar sagen und ich gehe ganz stark
davon aus das ist dieses jahr wesentlich
mehr verletzte und auch mehr angriffe
gegen beamte
und ordnungshüter geben wird weil die
leute wirklich ja die schnauze voll
haben auf berlinerisch gesagt und sich
das nicht bieten lassen wären und ich
gehe ganz klar von mehr verletzten aus
weil es kein legales geprüftes
ungefährliches feuerwerk gibt das heißt
die leute werden sich ja wie man auch in
den medien gerade sie teilweise ihre
böller selbst basteln und das mit
fatalen konsequenzen
dann hoffen wir dass das genau nicht
eintritt vielen dank ihn aber für ihre
zeit und für alles gute für die zukunft
dankeschön
vielen dank
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren